now joining us from sports illustrated
uh this man knows the ins and the outs
of the college football world and i've
got lots of questions to bounce off of
him he's pat 40 how are you pat
i'm good rich i have no good answers by
the way you know what
because you know what but nobody has any
good answers i mean
nobody even those who those who have
canceled the fall season those who are
still hoping to have a fall season
yeah namely somebody's got a good answer
nobody pretty much nobody that's i wrote
last week that everyone in college
sports is miserable because
nobody is sure what's the right thing to
do nobody is sure what is the right
thing to do
and and uh it does appear right that the
big ten and pac-12
acted out of the right thing to do
but we're seeing uh quite a bit of
pushback from the big ten
from member schools from coaches who
clearly were not
given a heads up about all this what do
you know about the big ten vote
and the process that went down that
clearly still needs some clarifying even
though kevin warren the big ten
commissioner
did start speaking this past week about
it
yeah i talked to him after he released
that open
letter and i asked him i said can you go
into the details of the vote he said it
would not be prudent
uh i wish they would i wish the
individual schools the presidents who
have done
mostly have just kind of hidden in their
offices since then
to stand up and say yep i voted to
postpone or no i voted to play
you know unless i mean you're being paid
a lot of money
uh you sit in a very prominent position
you have to make difficult decisions
i don't think it needs to be a secret
decision i mean
this is not sitting on a jury in a
murder trial trying to decide whether
somebody needs to be put to death it's a
decision on whether to play football in
the fall or to try to play later it's
just not that damn
important to not be able to put your
name behind how you voted in my opinion
but
that's where we are and i think that's
part of the reason for the
frustration that i think has gone way
over the top from
a lot of people in the big ten but the
the the issue is though
is that whether it was 12 to 2 or 14
nothing or or or even
you know what would it be that would be
so darn close if it was
you know uh eight to four or even closer
than that
you know i guess what would it be you
would put putting pressure on the
schools that said no
or um you know putting pressure on the
schools that said yes if they find out
that this was
was the prudent decision down the road
they're scared of the backlash from
disappointed angry fans
and frankly from coaches that have
helped whip up that sentiment online
and even athletic directors that have
done the same uh there's a lot of angry
fans and they've been there's been a lot
of oxygen
pumped into that anger from people
actually associated with the schools
and it's made it a difficult situation
but i just i wish the big ten would have
been
upfront early on right away
you know when when they had their first
meetings to decide this a take the vote
right away be
let us know what the vote is see move on
but they have not handled this
terribly well and people just refuse to
move on but it's not as if pat 40 of si
here
it's not as if the big ten is standing
alone pat the pac-12 made the same
decision the next day but it seems to me
that
that that hasn't received nearly the
amount of blowback
am i missing something or has there been
a parental if not member school blowback
towards larry scott
and the school presidents uh in the
pac-12
act that i've heard of and you know yes
you can say partially okay the pac-12
immediately released their basically
their medical reasons why and that was a
good move and the big tent didn't do
that
but still this is so far out of co out
of perspective it seems to me
you know is that i mean the pac-12
coaches athletic directors players and
parents have said okay
we understand the decision and
everywhere else
the mountain west okay we understand the
decision the mid-american conference we
understand the decision
40 percent of the fbs ranks are not
playing
more than half of division one is not
playing if you go to the fcs level so
it's not like the big ten is standing
alone made some rash
outlier decision here it's just that
their fans and their people refuse to
handle it
you know up to it including this amazing
scene
at the big 10 headquarters today when a
bunch of big 10 parents
came in i i don't know where they landed
their helicopter
but the helicopter parents all showed up
to to protest
and it's like what is
is that really is this the most
important thing you could be doing on
this friday is to
to fly to new to chicago to stand
outside
a building that nobody's probably in
because they're working from home
because there's a pandemic
i i'm just flabbergasted by this well i
mean is it
so what is it that
would this happen if jim delaney was
still there i mean is it a kevin warren
issue is is that what it is again we're
talking about the former
big ten commissioner in the current one
pat
yeah i i think the result may have still
been the same
they may have decided it later they
certainly would have handled
the outcome of the decision differently
i think
i think delaney would have had all of
the key people at keith's institutions
out front talking to the local media
saying yep
we had to do it you know barry alvarez
would be in front of a microphone the
president of wisconsin the president of
michigan the president michigan state
the president
of penn state you know they would have
been
taking this on i think at least they
would have been strongly encouraged to
do so by delaney and delaney himself
probably would have been a little more
forceful in his delivery of things so
there's no doubt about that but look
kevin warren's been on the job less than
a year
i don't know whether he has the
relationships with these presidents to
even put the
put the heat on them to say i need you
to step up and help make this thing go
smoothly
uh you know i mean he's been on the job
eight months
and for the first two and a half months
things were okay and ever since then all
hell has broken
broken loose as he said he said i have
been run trying to run the conference
with a telephone and a laptop in the
zoom calls
it hasn't been easy pat 40 senior writer
of sports illustrated here in the rich
eisen show let's just put a pin in the
big ten
for for a second what what are the other
conferences
hoping or what do they are they just
reading the science and saying
this is something we can deal with um
you know how how has there been such a
different reading in the sec
uh big 12 and then the acc i mean
north carolina sent their kids home this
week so
what's up with that i mean
it's fascinating and it's kind of where
our country is right now
same set of facts are viewed very
differently by different people in
different parts of the country for their
own
different purposes and so
you know i they they want to play in the
south they want to play
in the southwest where most of the big
12 is and parts of the midwest they want
to play up the atlantic seaboard
for now but as you said there's there's
issues in the acc and we'll see if the
resolve is there
i mean north carolina not only suspended
classes but as you said
send the student body home but not the
athletes they're supposed to stay
notre dame suspended classes in person
hadn't sent anybody home yet but they
stopped all campus activities but
they do expect to practice football this
weekend north carolina state
suspended in-person classes but they're
keeping right along with football
so to me this you know this is kind of
an indication
of of exactly how weak the ncaa and
college
college uh institutions position has
has become about these guys are just
regular students they don't deserve any
more pay
you know they don't deserve any
compensation now that they're very
clearly
being kept on campus for one reason they
need football
no and pat i had dr brian heinlein the
chief medical officer of the ncaa
uh on the program on monday and he
reiterated what he told to cnn over the
weekend which is the testing
in this country is such a disaster that
you can't have sports
you certainly can't have sports for all
four uh
fall programs you can't do it properly
and
that's been that's the reason why they
canceled all
college championships for the fall which
he said is the only thing that they
truly can control
and i pointed out that in the same way
that he
you know was pointing out the lack of a
national strategy
as a u.s government has created the
situation and testing that does not
allow for sports
that what about the fact that there
clearly is no national strategy here
from the ncaa level and allowing all the
conferences to do
what they want to do locally isn't that
the same thing that our federal
government has done
on testing and his answer was yeah you
know
but that's a fair question but and he
pointed out that
the science that they've put out there
is on their website for everyone to see
and that they cannot control what the
conferences do they can only control
the conference championship that the a
national championship and that there
won't really be one and then we're
starting to hear about the cfb
being able to do whatever they want to
do anyway right pat i mean that's
the way it currently looks like right
now absolutely yes no and this is the
the great fundamental failing of college
sports
in the ncaa itself is that that
when it comes to football there are the
five crime families
and then there are five other families
and there's nobody in charge and nobody
looking out for the best interests of
the sport
and quite frankly if you tried to put a
commissioner in charge right now
you think they're going to say yes you
think greg sankey wants somebody over
him telling him what to do when he when
the sec can already do whatever
it wants no so this is the situation
they created
uh back in the 1980s when they basically
went out on their own to make their own
tv contracts
and make a ton of money but that's it is
there is no uniformity and i don't blame
parents i don't blame players i don't
blame fans for being
frustrated by that by the complete lack
of a uniform stance this is what we
should do
as a whole in college football or this
is what we shouldn't do
uh and lacking that you know look mark
emmert is probably the most relieved guy
out there because he doesn't have to
make a call
on what the football conferences do he
can sit back and watch them all squirm
and come to their own tortured decisions
but we would be much better served i
think if there was one decision for the
entire country
well i think i guess just uh to bring
this full circle
uh and remove that pin on the big ten um
the the lawsuit that nebraska's parents
are threatening
uh to bring to the big ten um and the
commissioner
unless he coughs up the final tally and
and all the
notes regarding the uh decision making
on it
and that you know kovid as we all know
has attacked
anybody's weak spot family professional
whatever weak spot that is out there
um whether it's societal whether it is
health whether it is familial whether it
is personal
covid finds a weak spot places its
figurative thumb on it and presses
and price places pressure do you think
that the decision-making that the big
ten made and the pac-12 made
and that the sec and the other schools
are making do you think at the heart of
it
is the fact that college football needs
to pay their players
and that the only way to have a safe
college football season is to do what
all the professional sports leagues did
which is to have representatives of
management on one side and
representatives of the players on the
other side and come up
with a plan in which it all works out
and that everybody has to agree and that
there is no representation for players
because they're student athletes and
right now
we have to come up with a new term i
came up with it pat it's called
online student on-field athlete that's
basically what they
like it that's what they are like and
that that's what
do you think that that is truly what is
at the heart of everything that the
two conferences that said canceled that
don't want to deal with this issue
and the three conferences that are still
continuing it are saying the way that
we're dealing with this issue is we're
going to keep saying we're playing until
we can't
what do you think yeah oh yeah no i you
know what
bottle everything you said because
you're exactly right that that is
the the fundamental reason college
athletics is in this
ridiculous tortured state is because
they have tried ever since their
inception
to pretend that athletes are just
normal students and don't create revenue
for the schools
and so the the insistence on that stance
has clouded or informed every single
decision that's been made and if there
were
if if the name image and likeness stuff
had gone through a year ago we would
probably be a lot closer to being able
to play but still if you want to take it
the next step further
to make sure that you would have more
people able to play
yes would probably be if there were a if
there were a player representation if
there was a union of some kind if there
was collective bargaining if there was
an agreement that was put forward by the
conferences that says
here's what we were asking you to do and
the representatives can say yes we will
do it or no we won't
and then the players can opt out if they
want individually but
collectively they can either go forward
or not go forward and
lacking that and kind of this entire
charade that we've been putting up with
in college sports for decades
this has been exposed now more than ever
in the history of college sports no
doubt about it pat cause again look you
know i want
my school to play football in the worst
way i mean i can't imagine a fall
without michigan football
right i it's i i want it and then
hearing how the seeing a schedule being
put out
and then a week later having it saying
forget it and then
seeing my school's coach basically say
we've got the protocols to make it work
and then other member schools the big
ten saying the same damn thing we've got
the protocols to make it work as a
matter of fact we've been spending weeks
putting it together
and it is working we can make this work
but knowing that there are other member
schools that might not
right and that there are other programs
on the campus that want fall sports that
don't have that sort of possibility
that's why it would take some sort of
national league
to come in and say well member schools
that can't do it here's some money to
make sure that you can
and then other other sports here's some
money that makes sure that you can and
there's no possibility of that happening
right like we can't get together and
come up with the plan
and be reasonable as parents are asking
in college coaches are saying
they wouldn't want to be part of that
discussion you can't have that
discussion if you're saying well you're
just a student athlete
that's it yeah right no that's the
fundamental flaw and
and as we've you know the the myriad
attempts over the years to try to fix
the flaw to
to address the system all run into this
first of all
philosophical intransigence secondly
economic entrance just because they
don't want to share the money
but thirdly then just the the monumental
bureaucracy of the ncaa
which is well you know we need 19
different committees to study this for a
year and a half and then we can maybe
bring it to a vote six months after that
and then we'll see if that gets passed
and we can maybe implement it in 2024.
you know i assume it's just it is so
hard to get anything done
given the bureaucracy that the college
supports labor is under
all right last one for you then pat is
uh what when do you think what's the
fail-safe point by which the three other
uh power five big five conferences
who are saying let's still wait and see
what's the failsafe point by which they
make this go or no go decision
do you think you know i i think they are
gone until they are no go like i
intend to play for the play and we'll
stop only if
things reach a point where they just
feel like it's untenable
and you know it was fascinating really
interesting where
the big 12 was the fulcrum on this whole
thing like the acc was going to play
if the sec was going to play but they
needed that third power 5 league to do
it
big 12 decides okay we're in now you got
the majority but if one of them drops
out then do the other two say oh we
don't have a majority anymore i guess
we're all out
uh so i think we're waiting just to see
if they all three of those
stay in there and that's why what's
going on in the acc is so interesting
with the three schools that are running
into problems on campus
uh and you know i i don't know nobody
there's another problem of course rich
nobody has ever articulated a definitive
this number of cases we stop this number
of problems we stop you know there's
nothing
written in stone so it's all just like
uh we'll see how we're doing
and so nobody knows nobody knows what
the fail-safe date is nobody knows what
the fail-safe data
is it's all just kind of let's see how
we can do this and if we run into enough
blowback maybe we
won't pat i've loved the conversation
but i think we've literally just chased
the tale because we started by saying
nobody had any good answers and i think
we've ended with that too
exactly if i'm not mistaken that
literally just happened but i i
appreciate the call in the conversation
and we'll have it again soon hopefully
thanks for the call all right thanks
rich right back at you that's pat 40 of
sports illustrating
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here